البدايه بتطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث ذكرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
اسقطت مقاتلتين اوكرانيتين من طراز سوخوي
25 في كل من دنيوسك كما اعلنت السلطات
الروسيه احباط هجوم بمسيره على موسكو فجر
اليوم تاتي هذه التطورات بينما قال مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي ان مشاورات ستجرى
مع الكونجرس بشان ارسال طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا بعد انتهاء تدريب الطيران
الاوكرانيين على استخدامها وفي حديث مع
الجزيره اكد الناطق باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان حصول كياف على طائرات اف 16
سيغير شكل الحرب نتابع مع شبكه مراسلنا
هذه الاخبار ينضم الينا من موسكو امين
درغامي من واشنطن ناصر الحسيني ومن
سلوفيانسك ايضا مازن ابراهيم امين ابدا
معك اطلعنا على التطورات من وجهه نظر
موسكو خاصه ما يتعلق
بمحاولات استهداف موسكو بمسيره اوكرانيه
الى
تمثيليات لوزاره لعدد من الوزارات في تلك
المنطقه وهي غير بعيده عن مركز المدينه
التي يضم ايضا مبنى الحكومه الروسيه التي
يطلق عليها البيت الابيض اضافه الى المبنى
الرئيسي لوزاره الخارجيه هيئه الطيران
الفيدراليه الروسيه كانت قد اعلنت عن
الغاء القيود التي كانت قد فرضتها فجر
اليوم بالتزامن مع دخول هذه المسيره الى
اجواء العاصمه الروسيه وقالت بان حركه
الطيران عادت الى المطارات الاربعه الكبرى
في العاصمه موسكو
وايضا جوكوفسكي وكانت الهيئه في وقت سابق
قد حولت مسار عدد من الرحلات التي كانت في
طريقها الى هذه المطارات الاربعه الى
العاصمه البيلاروسيه مينسكي الى مدينه
سامبيترسبورغ وايضا الى مدينه نيجلي نوف
جراد طبعا كل هذا ياتي بعد ان اعلنت
السلطات الروسيه على انها تمكنت من اخماد
حريق اندلع في
وحده لتخزين بميناء
نوفوراسيسك في جنوب روسيا طبعا لم تعلن في
المقابل عن اسباب اندلاع هذا الحريق ميناء
مدينه نوفرسيسك على البحر الاسود كان في
وقت سابق قد تعرض لهجمات تامه السلطات
الروسيه الجانب الاوكراني
بتنفيذها باستخدام طائرات مسيره عدا ذلك
وزاره الدفاع الروسي اليوم ايضا اكدت
اسقاط مقاتلتين اوكرانيتين وعلى انها
استهدفت عددا من المقر
المقر القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وتجمعات للقوات وايضا مخازن السلاح في عدد
من الجبهات اضافه الى انها تحدثت عن
استهداف طبعا مقرات عسكريه اوكرانيه في
مقاطعتي لوغانسك
وا ايضا في مقاطعه خرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا
شكرا لك امين في موسكو ناصر في وقت قالت
على ضوء اخضر من واشنطن لتزويد اكياس
بطائرات اف 16 جيجا يقول قبل ساعه من الان
تقريبا بان البيت الابيض سيتشاور مع
الكونغرس لارسال طائرات اف 16 عبر طرف
ثالث الى كياف كيف نفهم هذا الكلام
نعم هي اليات اداريات داخليه يريد البيت
الابيض بشكل باخر الا يتحرك بمفرده كرئيس
للولايات المتحده يريد ان يكون له ذلك
الدعم لحزبي من الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
هذه اليات معروفه
تكنولوجيا امريكيه يسيطر الكونغرس على
عمليه
التصدير للدول الصديقه او غير الصديقه
وبالتالي يفهم ان الرئيس الامريكي في هذه
الحاله وهو مقبل على ما يبدو على حرب
طويله الامد لا شك انه سيطالب هذا
الكونغرس بالمزيد من الاموال مستقبلا يريد
ان يكون له ذلك الضمان السياسي من حزب
جمهوريه المعارض والحزب الديمقراطي ونحن
على فتره انتخابات التي تستعد لها
الولايات المتحده يريد ان يكون له ذاك
الدعم داخل الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه كي
يرسل رسائله الى بقيه العالم وهو ان
امريكا موحده في هذه الحرب وبالتالي
الشكليه اداريه حول التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
التي يجب توصيرها للاصدقاء واضح جدا ان
الرئيس الامريكي بشكل او باخر سيح على هذا
الدعم مستقبلا لكن نتحدث عن طائرات اف 16
يجب اولا تدريب التياريها وهم حسب معلومات
اكيده لن يكونوا جاهزين قبل العام المقبل
قبل الخريف المقبل نحن امام
فتره انتظار لسنه تقريبا كي تتمكن هذه
الطائره الامريكيه التي سيتم تسليمها
للاوكرانيين عبر الطرف الثالث حسب
القوانين الامريكيه لكن رئيس اعطى ضمانات
في رساله
امريكيه انهم هم الطرف الثالث الذي يزود
الاوكرانيين بالتدريب والطائرات لكن في
العمليه العسكريه حقيقه بعيدا عن الجانب
السياسي والاليات هناك شكوك كثيره الان
بدات تدخل على العقليه الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه يرى الامريكيون البيت الابيض
ايضا ولو انه لم يقوله الصراحه بان هذه
الهجمه المضاده الاوكرانيه لم تاتي ثمره
حقيقه الدفاعات الروسيه
صامته حتى الان ودخول اف 16 على مسرح يعني
كما قال الاوكراني المتحدث للجزيره قبل
قليل بالفعل سيغير مجرى وشكل هذه الحرب
حتى الان ترون حربا تعتمد على القوه
البريه ولكن ولكن هناك عامل
بعد عده اشهر والقلق الامريكي ان لا ينجح
الاوكرانيون في هذه الهجمات ولنستمع الى
ما يقوله سلفا عندما يتحدث عن طائره الاف
16 هي الان ضروره لهذه المعركه لان
الاوكرانيين يفتقدون لهذا السلاح والامل
كل العمل ان يتمكنوا وان ينجحوا على الارض
لكن هناك ايضا مضادات روسيا وتحديات حقيقي
على الارض سلفا هذه المره
قمنا هذا الاسبوع باطفاء الطابع الرسمي من
خلال رساله من الوزير بلينكن الى نظرائه
الاوروبيين ومفادها ان الولايات المتحده
ستكون مستعده لنقل طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا بالتشاور مع الكونجرس وبعد
الانتهاء من تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
وللاجابه عن جميع الاسئله باختصار عمليه
نقل الطائرات ستكون بعد الانتهاء من
التدريبات ونحن نعمل مع الكونجرس لتفعيل
ذلك مع حلفائنا
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اقل جزيره ان دخول اف 16 سيغير مجرى الحرب
ما شكل التغيير الذي تسعى اليه السلطات
الاوكرانيه في هذه الحرب طويله الامد كما
قالت شيك سالفن مع روسيا
في الواقع جلال صحيح ان ذوي المدافع اليوم
وصوت المعركه كان مرتفعا ولكن بطبيعه
الحال طغى عليه الضوء الاخضر الامريكي
والذي اعلن عنه من اكثر من مصدر واهمهم
وابرزهم بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ما جاء على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الدنماركي الذي قال
بان طائره الاف سته عشر ستصل الى اوكرانيا
هذا المعطى هو معطى اساسي بالنسبه للقياده
السياسيه والعسكريه الاوكرانيه لائحه
المطالب عندما بدات هذه الحرب على مستوى
التسليح كانت طويله بدات بالمدرعات
بالقذائف بالصواريخ وما الى ذلك من معطيات
ترتبط بحركه المشاه الميدانيه المباشره في
محاوله لصد القوات الروسيه المتقدمه على
اكثر من محور ولكن كلما كانت القوى
الغربيه والدول الغربيه تؤمن بعضا من
المتطلبات الاوكرانيه على مستوى التسليح
سواء بالمدرعات والعربات والدبابات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه والالمانيه اضافه
الى منظومات الصواريخ سواء كانت جافلين او
غيرها
كل هذا الامر كنا نصل الى نقطه تقول فيها
الاداره العسكريه والسياسيه الاوكرانيه
انها بحاجه الى نوعين اضافيين من السلاح
سيغيران شكل المعركه النوع الاول هو
الطائرات والمظله الجويه التي يمكن ان
تؤمنها على مستوى تقدم قواتها والمستوى
الثاني المرتبط بالسلاح وهو الصواريخ
بعيده المدى ويجري الحديث عن ما بين 300
كم الى 500 كيلومتر على مستوى الطائرات
كان هناك تشديد طيله الفتره الماضيه على
ان المتغير على مستوى الجبهه ضمن هذا
الهجوم المضاد الذي اطلقته اوكرانيا قبل
شهرين ونصف لن يتحقق دون مظله جويه تؤمن
تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه كنا نشاهد خلال كل
هذه الفتره بان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
التقدم على مستوى خط الجبهه سواء من خارجه
في دونيت في جابولوجيا كل تلك المحاور
كانت تصطدم بدفاعات روسيه سنويا اولا عن
مستوى حقول الالغام الشاسعه هذا من ناحيه
من ناحيه الخنادق التي تم حفرها بالاضافه
الى منظومه الصواريخ والمدفعيه التي تغطي
القوات الروسيه وتؤمن لها غطاء يضاف الى
كل ذلك الغطاء الجوي الاساسي الذي كبد
الاوكرانيين خسائر كبيره على مستوى
الغارات المستمره من الطيران الروسي والتي
كانت تحول دون تقضب ارتال الدبابات دون
تقدم الجنود الاوكراني خلال هجماتهم
وبالتالي التشديد اليوم على سلاح الطيران
وتحديدا الاف سته عشر هو كان المدخل
بالنسبه ولقاده اركانه عندما كانوا يشددون
اذا ما اردتم وذلك في في حديثهم لشركائهم
الغربيين اذا ما اردتهم تغيير المعادله
عليكم بمنحنا الطائرات على الاقل هكذا
تنظر اوكرانيا الى هذا الموضوع بوصفه بانه
سيغير مجرى الحرب وهذا ما تحدث به الناطق
باسم القوات الجويه في مقابلته مع الجزيره
فلنستمع اليه
سبق واعلنا حاجتنا للحصول على طائرات اف
16 منذ الاجتياح الروسي لذلك عملنا من
خلال القنوات الدبلوماسيه بجديه للوصول
الى الحدث التاريخي المتمثل بموافقه دول
على تزويدنا بهذه الطائرات مثلي هولندا
والدنمارك وحصلنا ايضا على ضوء اخضر من
الولايات المتحده سيتم تدريب طيارين جدد
وفرق هندسيه للعمل على صيانه هذه الطائرات
عندها سيتعرض الروس لضغط كبير فهذه
الطائرات ستقوم بتغيير شكل الحرب